wow
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh my gosh what leah is allergic to
latex and i don't know if they knew to
get her latex free eyelash glue
i do not think it's the latex free kind
no no
i mean she can't use it she'll swell up
like a balloon okay oh my god
i'm stressed out like
you know i don't want her to feel
stressed because i don't have what we
need and she needs the non-latex eyelash
glue for her face jess i'm sorry to
interrupt you i just realized that the
eyelash glue that's in there is not
latex-free so i'm going to the store i
wanted to let you know i'm going to get
her some i'm like falling down on my job
because i should have thought of that i
should be prepared for every situation
and i wasn't
i should've known if your kid needs
something special then you should
probably always have it with you just in
case you guys were walking in 15 minutes
what does that mean flashing is that i'm
seriously i'm can i go
[Music]
guys we got a performance in like 10
minutes if you don't need to be in here
get out if you're in here slap it on
quick
[Music]
i'm back what did i miss what am i not
doing i got it it's that kind right
no it's very stressful
i think
she was overreacting just a bit i think
she was a little stressed like it's okay
the glue is here you are fine okay no
one is stressing you're fine i'm already
ready okay i'm not stealing yourself
does anybody have baby wipes i spilt
a drink all over me
[Music]